[Music]
i have great pleasure to introduce our
first speaker today uh he is my
colleague
a good friend of mine and so without
further ado
like us all to join me in welcoming alex
gold
[Applause]
hey everybody uh like kelly said my name
is alex uh i'm here to talk today about
end-to-end data science deployment
with our markdown shiny plumber and pins
uh
the slides and code are available online
at rstd.io
deploy 2020. although as i'm saying this
i'm realizing that the slides are not
there yet
but they will be so look forward to that
um so
this this story starts as all great
stories do with with a shiny app
um and this this shiny app in particular
uses the capital bike share data so if
you're
if you don't know what the capital bike
share is the system of docked
uh bicycles in washington dc that's
that's what they look like that's what
the docks look like
you can rent a bike from a dock and
write it to a different dock and dock it
there
um and so you know what what i'm going
to try and do with this shiny app is
predict
the number of bikes at different
stations at different times so
uh where's my window here's my window so
this is what the app looks like
uh i've got a map of washington dc uh i
can click on a particular station you'll
see this is that 21st and
m and if i scroll down now i can see the
number of bikes that are available
at that station or predicted to be
available at that station about the next
24 hours
uh important maybe if i wanted to go get
a bike in dc at 8 pm tonight because
they're going to be none
at 21st m too bad uh
so let's let's talk a little bit about
sort of how how this app works
uh so the capital bikeshare uh
organization makes available an api
that provides real-time bike data how
many bikes are at each station
right now uh available on the api and
i'm going to import this using an
rmarkdown document
from there i'm going to build an xg
boost model to do all my prediction for
me i'm going to do that also in in our
markdown
i'm going to serve this this model with
a plumber api and if you're if you're
interested in plumber i'm not going to
talk a lot more about it right now
but hang out because like the rest of
this track is going to be a lot of
plumber so that'll be awesome
uh and then of course i'm serving this
to the the client app at the end and so
you know i had this app but but i wanted
to to take it further right it just
lives on my machine
i don't want to like walk my computer to
people um
to show them my app and so i knew where
i wanted to get to was you know
my shiny app is available all the time
to whoever
wants it the uh the model gets retrained
every day right like weather's gonna
change
different seasons i wanna be able to to
have uh
uh you know the model retraining
periodically and i need you this data
import every 20 minutes it's it's
real-time data so like once it's gone
it's gone and so i want to get those
real-time data pull them in
and and store them somewhere so that i
can do my predictions as you know sort
of a time series or panel kind of
kind of thing um so
i i'm there but that leads to like a
whole bunch of questions what what
should i
prioritize while i'm doing this there
are all these things that i could
want to do uh as i'm trying to like you
know sort of deploy this app and and
uh you know add some horsepower uh and
that's these are like
hard scary big questions and really what
they boil down
to is you know is my deployment
sophisticated enough am i doing it
for real or or not um of course i
i then you know did what i sometimes do
when i'm procrastinating which was i
started watching star wars uh just
because you know why not do that and
you all might know this guy uh green big
ears
talks funny uh he's the jedi master yoda
of course and and he says this line in
the middle of one of the movies
uh size matters not look at me judge me
by my size do you and i thought this was
really appropriate right like
if you just sub in the word like
sophistication here right like this is a
great way to think of
why do we care about deploying shiny
apps and of course we care because we
want to increase
value we want to provide value
sophistication is irrelevant right
are you providing value is the right
question and so
um how do we deploy to to increase value
how was i going to do that
um and and so there were sort of three
principles that i took as
as my guides and the first one was that
i wanted to make my content accessible
and what that meant is that people who
should have access to the content can
get it when they need it and somewhere
that they know where to find it
uh the second thing was reproducible
right can i can i reliably understand
how the content exists why it is the way
it is can i sort of audit it
and then and then secure and that's sort
of the inverse of accessible right
should people who
don't people who shouldn't have access
don't have access that's
that's uh that's pretty important um
so you know the the question is how do i
get there and this is honestly uh
not a trivial problem right uh in
particular in between those important
train steps with my data i have to
store that data somewhere and then in
between training and serving the model i
have to store that model
somewhere and until recently this wasn't
a solved problem um
you know i i i could put it the analysis
data in a database if i if i have one
handy if i have write privileges to one
that's
that's fine but if i if i don't or if i
don't want to put it in a database for
some reason
there kind of was no good answer there
and and similarly with
with modeling um there was kind of no
good answer
so i i went i went back to star wars
went back to uh
you know not working on this because
that was that was easier
and of course yoda um came to my came to
my rescue
yet again uh saying you know when
hopeless the task seems
come out with a sweet new r package
someone will like
it's inevitable you know and of course
that was true uh the pins package is a
new package by javier larashi he's here
at rstudio
and this is this is a super cool package
i'm super excited about it
basically what it lets you do is take
something an r object
put it somewhere else and then get it
back when you want it this is sort of
the essence of the pins package
but let's go into a little more detail
about exactly how it works
so i'm going to start off with my my
rmir studio session i have an object i
want to save you can think like a data
frame
it could also be a model it could be any
sort of s3 compliant object
and you know i have a board also and my
board is where i'm going to save it
pins currently supports a bunch of
different boards um so rsu connect
kaggle github azure google cloud
platform s3 or a website
uh javier is constantly adding new
boards i will also add so if you
want something that isn't here like put
it on github and it'll probably have it
done before the end of conf it's kind of
incredible
uh but that aside it supports a lot of
different places you can put your data
great so uh it's really easy to use as
well you uh put your data onto the board
with the pins
pin command and get it back with the
pins pin
get commands let me let me show you how
this works just to be a little more
a little more concrete here um
so the the way this works is that i've
got my
uh my pins let me make this bigger for
y'all
better it's probably easier to see right
uh so i'm going to load up the pins
package
i'm going to register my board in this
case i'm registering our studio
connection that just this just means you
know this is a board you can talk to
with to the r station so it's going to
register it takes just a moment
and then i'm going to pin my data to the
board right it's
pin whatever the object is i'm pinning
the name of the object and the board
where it's going and it's going
taking a moment to load and so here i am
in the connections pane and you can see
that
like any other type of connection like a
database connection it loads up right
here
and if what i've pinned is a data frame
i can actually see what's going on there
i can see the different fields
in my data frame and i can also go over
here i can preview the table i can see
the first thousand rows this is empty
cars they're only 32 but you know
you could see up to a thousand and then
if i want to get the pin
back i just run this pin get command
saving it to a local a local file and
now i've got mt cars back and to me this
is this is so
so cool because what what's happened now
is
instead of having to email around data
or having to save data somewhere and
then tell everybody where it is and
you know version two final actually
final alex fine right none of that
right the person needs to know the name
of the board or the the url of the board
and they need to know what the name of
the
pin is and then what they get when they
do a pin get is
always the newest version right this is
the thing that's really exciting is like
the newest version is always available
on this pin
so oops
so so the question is sort of you know
what are good things depending on what
are bad things obviously you don't want
to just like
store every single r object you've ever
used
um in in a pin so uh some
again wisdom from yoda uh just before
luke goes off to fight vader at cloud
city and
it's a anyway um before that though yoda
gives him some very some very sage
advice
uh best considered a caching mechanism
pins are
and and and what this means a it's kind
of you know this movie came out in 1980
and
this package came out in 2020 so like
this is very impressive to begin with
but uh even more impressive that he's
right and so
uh you know you generally don't want to
save your data of record
in a pin right it's it's not a database
it doesn't have all the like
bells and whistle of a database being
able to audit not a database replacement
um what pins are great for is is they're
great for something
that you could compute at the time or
you could get at the time but it's
easier
to store it somewhere right you'd rather
cache it rather than
uh recreating it on demand and so there
are three attributes that good
candidates for a pin have and that is
that they're relatively small say like
a gigabyte there's no hard rule but a
gigabyte is a good a good rule of thumb
they're reused that you actually want
this thing over and over and over again
uh in different pieces of your content
and that they're they're current you
right you want the tip of the pin you
only care about the newest version if
you care about archival versions
a pin is not a great choice but if you
care about just the newest one that's
really good
and again you know pins are for things
you can recreate uh you know it's not
for your data of record
um that that's not a great choice i mean
if you do it
whatever i'm not gonna stop you but
officially recommending against that
um so let me show you let's go back to
our our bike app here
and and just show a little bit of where
pins show up in this app we're very
zoomed in
and so you know here we have the app
right rinder this is what our app looks
like we've got a map we click on the map
we get
the prediction of the number of bikes at
different stations throughout
um and so there are a couple places that
pins show up here and i'm gonna be very
honest this app is quite the code that
goes in here is quite large
uh it demos a lot of different things so
i'm gonna sort of like go real quick
through a couple little things here
uh and ignore a lot of the rest of the
code so that's just how it's gonna go
sorry
uh and so when i go to my my pins here
um i have my my ingest and tidy part
here right this is where i'm pulling in
from the api
so i'm i'm registering with both my
database connection
right that's this that's this line 15.
and in line 16 and 17 i'm registering
the pins board because i'm going to put
things in both places
so first i'm going to do is i'm going to
pull down from the api the number of
bikes
oh interesting maybe i should run this
line first there we go
um and so what i'm going to do is i'm
going to pull down the number of bikes
and you can see this is just a data
frame that came back
all this code in here is just sort of
interpreting the api call
and you know what i'm doing is i'm just
pulling in the station id and the number
of bikes available these are really
sort of the most important fields to me
this is going to be like my target when
i'm doing my my machine learning
and then i'm going to write this to my
database right that's getting written to
my database
and that's actually scheduled to happen
on our studio connect every 20 minutes
so
that's great taking care of the next
piece though and this is what i'm going
to pin
so this data frame this data frame
this is the station information so this
is it's those ids those station ids
which are just numeric
but i have the names here which is what
i'm putting you know pop up there in the
app
i'm putting up the latitude and
longitude which i'm going to use both to
put them on the map and also as a
feature in my machine learning model
as well as the capacity of the stations
which is also an important feature of my
machine learning model and this
is a perfect candidate for a pin it's
it's small it's less than 600 rows
i reuse it several different times
across this piece of of content
and i always want the most current
version right on my map i don't want to
be showing stations that don't exist or
that have moved or anything like that
and so this is what i'm going to be
pinning in my code
similarly then when i go on to build my
my xg boost model um
again i'm going to skip a lot through
some code here but you can see that i'm
pulling in another pin here this is my
modeling parameters actually that
i'm writing elsewhere but what i really
want to show is down here i'm training
my model with
with parsip parsnip xgb train and then
what i'm saving here
is this list object right this is like
this could be a formal s3 object it's
not it's just a list
right but i have my model i'm saving
some metadata with it as well the
training date the splitting date
between my testing and training set and
the recipe that i'm using from the
recipes package
to actually make my training data and
then i'm pinning that
here onto rcu connect and this is super
useful right now i have a really good
way
to know what i've done and then last in
my plumber api that's serving those
predictions
uh i've got you know my model i'm
reading it in here
and then all this code basically is just
sort of interpreting
the uh the input from the api
and making sure it's ready to be fed
into the model and then down here right
i'm running that predict command
on that model that's that's from the pin
um and this is you know purring away on
on our studio connect and and so you
know i can
come here to the swagger uh interface
and get back you know these are the
predictions first station 75
i don't know what station that is but
that's why i have the the other one the
other pin with the station names
so um that's that's how pins sort of fit
into into this app so now i've got a
solution for this right for my analysis
data i can do it in a database
or in a pin for my model i can do it in
a pin
um one thing i do want to say is like
these are just slots and you can put
whatever you want into these slots so
for example
you know if you're if you're using some
model in python or some import model
method in python you can totally do that
and use reticulate to go back and forth
between r and python super easily
um if if what you're serving isn't a
model if it's you know plots
or just some kind of counting right that
the same principle
totally works uh and when you're sharing
right if you're if what you've got is an
r markdown document that you want to
render and email out or something like
that
again think of these as slots uh you
know
my version happened to be our market on
our markdown plumber shiny app but yours
can be whatever you want
okay so pins has really helped me a lot
make this this content more accessible
more reproducible but i haven't really
addressed security at all and that's
that's a really
important piece here uh the the security
of of my app and so
of course i went back to yoda and you
know in return of the jedi as yoda is
dying fading away after 800 years of
training jedi knights
witnessing the downfall okay um sorry i
really like star wars
uh he gives this one final piece of
advice to luke and he says deploy to the
right server
and secure your data will be uh which
you know
i think is very very prescient of him uh
and so you know
you can do this in in an open source way
if you know that's that's what you're
more comfortable doing for this
important training step you know put it
on a server any server that has r works
you can use a cron job if you want to
schedule it um for your analysis date
and your model you can use
you know if you have a database for the
database stuff or a pins board i showed
there like a whole bunch of options
right
for serving the model any server with r
again can work
um you do have some things you have to
be delicate with here around around how
auth works
right so you can do that with networking
rules you could put a proxy in front of
it
you can like route it through a lambda
gateway to take care of api keys
you have lots of options but you're
going to want to do something to secure
this
this api and then for sharing you have a
lot of options if it's an r markdown
document either a website or a rendered
document
netlify is a great choice shiny server
open source
is is available to you and shiny apps i
o is also an option which
is not open source but is relatively uh
affordable so
you know that that can be a really good
option here if you're doing like a
private thing or something that's for
for your own use um of course we see a
lot of organizations that sort of
struggle with pieces of this either they
don't want to manage this many sort of
separate pieces
um they don't their their it
organizations don't want to manage stuff
in r we see that a lot that's
that's totally fine and so and so of
course sort of easy mode here
is our professional product our studio
connect and that takes care of a lot of
these pieces
for you right it it can deal with the
api keys it can deal with scheduling the
r markdown documents
uh it can deal with securing the the
plumber apis it can deal with you know
accessibility controls and that kind of
stuff and you can put pins on our studio
connect
um so this can be a really a really
useful way uh
to to to do all of this so
uh big takeaways um when you are
thinking about deploying
content uh the the top three things to
really
optimize for are accessibility uh
reproducibility and security
right if you're hitting these three keys
you're probably increasing value
um with what you're doing as opposed to
just
adding sophistication um while you're
doing that our markdown shiny
plumber and pins are good friends of
yours
and of course may the force be with you
thanks everybody
i'm gonna put this down so all right all
right so
uh i failed to mention at the top of
things here but
if you have questions we're gonna
continue using slido as we did in the
keynotes so
we're in grand ballroom b so if you have
a question
go to the same slido page select grand
ballroom b and you can enter your
questions there or vote on questions
that are already asked there
so i'm going to ask alex some questions
here since we have a couple minutes
um maybe this was covered in the last
half of your presentation but you do you
want to readdress
how pins is different from a well
organized shared file system with
correct
acls yeah that's a that's a great
question um
it to be honest under the hood it's not
that different right you have the same
kind of
uh control and access controls the the
main difference is that it's a very r
centric answer and so you can from
within r address those objects
uh without having to go through the
hassle of figuring out you know how your
shared file system works
uh finding things and that sort of thing
so from from an i.t perspective maybe
not that different uh but from the
perspective of an r developer
it's a very different sort of
development experience it's much more
straightforward
yeah this next one we we get a lot so
i'm
happy to ask it here what's the the
benefit of using
a plumber api for saving the object to
s3 and then calling it with a shiny app
oh that's a great question i love that
question um
there are a couple benefits um one is
that that you can the biggest benefit to
me
and this happens in several different
ways is that it decouples
the logic of serving the the model
from the logic of displaying whatever
you're displaying or doing something
else with it so you decouple those
things
and that makes your life easier it makes
your life easier in a couple ways one of
them is is purely like from a code
perspective
it makes it easier to write the code
because you write your plumber api to
serve the model
you write your shiny app or whatever it
is to consume the model and you get to
sort of separate those
those concerns which which is really
nice the other piece from a performance
perspective you can test those two
things independently
right you can test the plumber api with
say the load test package which i think
some people might be talking about
next uh and then you can test the shiny
app separately right you can decouple
both the coding and the performance
issues between the api and the uh
the app which is great excellent
okay next is there a limit to the amount
of data you should be
using with pins
it depends on which board you're using
there some of those boards do have
limits to how much you can save
um you know my suggestion would be that
if you're saving more than a gigabyte's
worth of data
there's probably a better solution for
for what you're doing
um and that's totally a rule of thumb
not a
you know a real thing but um just in
general if you're finding yourself doing
more than that
uh you're you're probably saving an
object that's bigger than pins really is
designed for
um one one thing that can be helpful is
if you're saving model objects
often the model objects package up a lot
of stuff with it that you don't
necessarily want like the training data
and that could make your model really
big and you know sort of inflate the
size there is a package called butcher
um like you know person who makes meat
cuts
uh that you can use to sort of chop out
some of the stuff in your model object
you don't want and just save like
actually the model so
if you're saving models that can be a
useful thing to do
do one more here i like this one as well
is there a reason your
import and model training code is in our
markdown files
instead of playing our scripts yes
that's a great question i love it when
things that i put in the presentation
and then took out because i didn't have
time
come back in questions um yeah so i
really love our markdown for for two
main reasons um one is that it
encourages literate programming
that is interspersing uh code and prose
right because
you have just like a place to write
prose it doesn't even be comments you
just
write it and it's great um the other
reason that you have a record of what
you did so when you come back later
and your something has gone awry with
your model um you have output there
with the code of what actually happened
unlike if it's an r script and then
whatever happened was totally ephemeral
and it's gone forever
well everyone please join me in thanking
alex again thanks everybody
[Music]